hello trash Tuesday family we are
starting off today with a really really
big announcement it's so exciting oh my
God my earphones I'm so excited it's
actually so exciting we just needed to
switch some stuff up it was getting a
little bit yeah like we love a female
energy for sure but we also feel like we
want to be more I don't know like
Universal but also I will say like when
I did start this podcast when we all
started it it was like didn't you kind
of want it to be for guys I mean it
accidentally was for girls yeah that was
just an accident like it was cool like
we love having girl slugs but it was
like I do like to be in the male gaze
well I just think comedy is like for men
yeah and so we we decided to make a big
change
um it it took us a long time behind the
scenes to kind of orchestrate this but
it worked out it was
all amicable yeah no to absolutely 100
um and I went to skank first yes I
thought what better than getting like
some skank First Energy up in this [ __ ]
and it just so happens that when Annie
went to skink Fest she met someone there
that we felt like was going to be the
exact right fit for trash Tuesday and so
we are making the big change
and um we're really really excited to
introduce you guys to the new co-host of
trash Tuesday all right bring him out
bring him out his name is Kyle it's Kyle
he's uh
he won't ever say anything about being a
girl he's got really broad shoulders
Kyle what's up
tell us what you think our fans are
missing except little [ __ ]
today that everyone's called [ __ ]
instead of slugs now there I actually am
having sexual tension with Kyle
see it's like we can get a completely
different person here completely
different gender and Esther will still
have the same vibe
now you guys have questions for me yeah
Kyle what are your thoughts on Comedy
and comedians I think comedians have
their heads so far up their own asses oh
um name one name one and you know we'll
see where I go with it
[Laughter]
no
you know I work out with we go to the
same gym actually
um
Annie
Annie
whether you're starting small or scaling
up ship station makes ship happen
ship and grow more with ship station
this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
promo code trash Tuesday today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code trash Tuesday it's time to
talk about female hair thinning over
half of women will experience hair
thinning in their lifetime it's totally
normal we all have dealt with it your
hair story could help another woman join
the conversation at shed the silence.com
that's shed the silence.com guess what
slugs we're coming back for another
Wilder and crazier and way better live
stream yeah baby we're coming back
I'm scared we should have a doctor on
site monster are we even allowed to talk
about this I feel like we you've heard
enough and secret time and you see it
when you believe it you see it it's
going to be amazing so fun we are going
to be very interactive with you guys on
the live stream chat and it's all going
down November 17th at 7 pm Pacific time
again you can get your tickets at
moment.co trash Tuesday get tickets at
moment.co trash Tuesday all right you
guys I'm so excited sluggies I am on the
road I'm bringing uh Jesse Jet Ski juicy
Johnson with me to San Jose next weekend
on the 11th and 12th with Josh Potter
maybe that's two weekends from now I
don't know math or calendars it's gonna
be so fun please come out to that one I
will then be
um the 18th 17th and 18th I will be in
Plano Texas then
um we just added some more dates I'm
going to be in Las Vegas I'm going to be
in Michigan I'm going to be in a bunch
of places go to annieleterman.com shows
I cannot wait to meet you hi slugs my
tour is starting so soon it is time to
get tickets I'm coming to San Francisco
Seattle Portland and Phoenix my favorite
places you can get tickets at
estheronice.com I can't wait
hi you guys I've missed you uh-oh here
we are again I love you here we are I
love this Esther what I want to cuddle
you when you look like this we oh it I
had a feeling this was a very kalila
bathing shirt well it's it's actually it
makes me want to hold you tight what it
is is can I tell you what it is is that
Esther like has recently had her hair
and makeup done so it still looks good I
think so because she has and you're
falling for it because she kind of is
making it look like a little messy but
it's not it's because professionals were
involved it's true I'm holding on to it
for a few more days and I should legally
be able to but that's the hottest look
right like falling asleep in your makeup
what are you a masters movie what are
you gonna be in it
um you know Annie that's a really good
question oh because it's so interesting
everyone I seem to meet is in Esther's
movie including my ex-boyfriend it's
just so you know what's so crazy
um your new boyfriend Trevor too
um it's just everyone I run to it's like
it's like I'm bumping into the stars of
Esther's book I it's you know what it
reminds me of alone together it reminds
me a little bit of a loan together you
know I have I this is gonna sound fake I
literally have very little to do
wait one second Annie I am in the mood I
know you she's not gonna cover the
tattoo oh my character is by the way so
glad there's not an Annie on that one
that is one I'm not there's no fomo for
that you charge me for the dressing no
my character is a tiger rally fan I've
decided is that for real well no but
just in my head because there's a
freaking tattoo although it is confusing
because Bobby is is actually in the
movie so I don't know but you said that
this will be like a girl that my
character met in Hawaii in Hawaii yeah
that I fell in love with or something
had like a like a three-day just love
affair yeah that's very on on brand yeah
okay so also it's still disgusting
did I tell you
did I tell you I went on a date with a
girl
can I know more yeah what do you want to
know how do you know that how'd she
taste yeah I told Annie
while you were filming we were [ __ ]
each other [ __ ]
wait how did it go ask her she telling
you exactly how I went down yeah we went
down on each other okay well then that's
fine let's let's go again I don't that's
fine waxed for me I did I waxed her two
little Asian pubes
how was the date it was it was nice it
was nice but I don't think I'm I'm ready
for anything that was like proof that
like any I'm like she's like hot hot
chick hot chick super nice super can we
see a picture of her without anyone else
seeing her did you meet her online yeah
I turn my hinge on only to girls when I
was in Hawaii before
oh this was when you go over when you go
when you get out of the type of breakup
when you go to the breakup that you went
through
oh she's cute oh my God let me see um oh
my God give it to me now
I'm not gonna say anything
oh yeah that's exactly what that's
exactly what got me there I was like oh
can we say what that is the dog is like
the cutest thing ever
how's her body incredible she's hot
she's a hot chick well of course yeah
who am I asking wait this how did it go
this is where it gets weird whoa find
out Carlos this whole time has been like
really hoping that our prank was real
titties titties I know titties yeah you
stay out of this
it's just so pretty she have a deep
voice no she has like a very like soft
girly voice
she's really pretty we had a really good
time like we we drank a lot like it was
a really nice nice night does she know
who you are
um yeah that's weird
um a little bit Yeah but she was still
like super like chill about it but the
next day because I drank too much the
night before I preemptively ordered an
IV for the next day because I knew I
love an IV all right so I was like I
need my Myers cocktail my glutathione I
need all of these things so I I booked
it the night before so the next day I
get a phone call and it's a woman who
gets on the phone and she was like hey
um so and so was do you usually see this
person does this person is this person
your usual nurse I'm like yeah that
person is my nurse like he comes over
every time I need an IV she's like I'm
really sorry to have I'm really sorry to
have to tell you this but he passed away
oh my God and there I was just hung over
like feeling like I'm dying and now my
nurse is dead how did he die it was a
pulmonary embolism like a blood clot and
I was devastated that Sunday I was like
this is not going well wait this is
really how old was he young what the
[ __ ] incredible like he I loved having
him over doing my IV because he would
just he was just so he was wonderful he
was a wonderful nurse get ready
sleep
that is so sad I'm so sorry I know
no
if it if it helps my cousin died two
weeks ago is that funny
[Laughter]
this is someone that matters to her okay
this is her verse
how insensitive Esther my MERS die I'm
sorry I'm so sorry wait but how did your
cousin pass my petition
no it is obviously sad but I am awkward
with sad things please don't think I'm
like a sociopath but no my cousin was
struggling with breast cancer for 14
years wow and she passed away two weeks
ago
um which is so sad and you know that was
my mom's first niece and she was born
when my mom was 12. so like that was
like the little sister my mom always had
in the competition yeah
so did you name your miscarriage after
her oh my God Annie so repeating you
what you want so
um yeah I'm just I guess I'm just
relating I don't know why I brought it
up I feel awkward now change the channel
R.I.P to your cousin yeah it is sad it
is really tragic it's horrible breast
cancer get we need to get our checks
right let me just um since we're in the
game of one-upping yeah my half-sister
died of breast cancer she did at 28 yeah
at 28. guys in the Annie to honor the
one-upping I'm wearing like really
padded
I know my cancer
so there you go I hate breast cancer oh
my God I do too clip it there's the clip
just to be quiet I hate you did it like
extra like girl you're like hey we hate
it
um what else I actually okay I have a
mystery to present to you guys and how
possibly everyone in the world can be in
your movie except me oh my God and hey
don't do this to me no it's not a big
deal I'm used to it it's been how long
have you been friends
okay so Carlos I texted you a two tick
tocks last night the first one that I
sent you
I'm gonna ask you to play it but I want
to give you guys some context because
this is like wait before we do I was
about to make the wish off of it and go
I wish she would come up with an idea
that's not from Tick Tock
make a wish
Kyle would kiss me
okay so
you guys know I spend like all my free
time scrolling Tick Tock I found this
guy on tick tock
and
I feel this connection to him like he
just spits real facts he's kind of nerdy
and like very honest and he's weird in a
good way like he's very estry like this
feels like the kind of guy that like I
would have been best friends with in
preschool like something really weird
right I feel this connection to this guy
I feel like you would have hated
yourself what do you want you to hang
out with you would have been so annoyed
with you in preschool you both are like
I'm cold you'd be like I'm cold I'm cold
so
he is a mystery man like I don't know
who he is he's there's no evidence like
of of his real name of anything about
him however because I've watched all of
his tick tocks he's dropped two hints
that are really really interesting to me
and our world so the first hint is he
said actually his twin brother is famous
he has a famous twin brother and I've
checked all the comments no one knows
who it is okay and then in another Tick
Tock he mentioned that he's friends with
a lot of comedians I know who it is
it's Ramy Malik's twin brother this guy
does not look like Rami Malek oh you can
see his face it's not that he looks
exactly it looks exactly the no he
doesn't Okay so
again he has a famous twin he's six feet
tall is that Scarlett Johansson's
brother no dude well she's married to
Colin Jost
what is oh Annie you're really coming no
I know what Scarlet's twin looks like
because I've looked him up because he
literally looks like your twin and you
look like her it's very weird
um Carlos will you pull up the tick tock
so we can show the girls what he looks
like and his personality and see if
anyone [ __ ] can figure out who this
guy is does he use any filters no is it
a male no it's he stitched this video
and I also but the um you see his face
he's not hiding his face but there's
just hints and I'm like who is his
brother why does he know comedians
by the way and she never responded to me
that girl who's Tick-Tock this is really
yeah how did you ask her out on Raya I
know but what did you say I was probably
like hey hi how's your week going
just down there I feel like the
algorithm thinks you're too hot for my
level so like I only see people like
Bobby or something but like for you it's
like wait so you say you only have it on
Mel's and Bob if you're on the search
bicycle oh my God that's the twist you
guys Carlos and Bobby are kissing Bobby
wishes honestly I think I think he does
I really think so I think when he gets
upset about you and Kyla it's not
because of kalila he's over kalilah yeah
he's over okay
play this and we need to figure this out
all right she's bok choy
bunch
a little suspicious oh they're hiding uh
like off-brand schizophrenia essentially
uh the develop the ability oh so wait
can you pause yeah
he's talking right now about how if a
guy is too funny that they're
schizophrenic and you he's basically
talking in depth about how like
comedians are shady if they're funny
just listen but also observe the
mannerisms okay
oh they're hiding uh like off-brand
schizophrenia essentially uh the develop
the ability to become like a top tier
comedian is derived during the
Adolescent stage as a coping mechanism
but what happens is they get some
symptoms of schizophrenia so a second
voice develops but the second voice is
their own voice so it's like they're
here I don't know if I agree with this
but it's kind of like gaining control of
your intrusive thoughts in order to
produce funny jokes it's a lot like that
but you also get other symptoms like
introverted anhedonia which is like the
inability to like feel happiness so like
that's why you get the Trope of like the
depressed comic
um they also uh don't go like going to
therapy so it's like really hard to get
a comedian to go to therapy uh so like
getting anything treated it's like a
pain and pain in the ass because they
they think that they're smarter than all
therapists and understand the human uh
experience on a deeper level than a
therapist so that that's why they do
that people who are too funny uh you
should be suspect of okay
that a lot going on here a lot Bobby has
this theory that Koreans and Filipinos
are like the funniest Asians is because
we've had so much trauma
and that you know a lot of the comedy or
the intrinsic is like a coping mechanism
to always just kind of Jewish people too
right right
apparent woman funny why aren't we
why are we so unpunny we have to have
our period you guys are mean to us just
not funny at all it's so weird never
even funny
um
but
but yeah I don't know do you see how
this guy is like spitting out
introspective intelligent interesting
things that like couldn't look more
schizophrenic talking about other people
being schizophrenic I mean he literally
is talking and looking like a
schizophrenic all the comics were like
chill bro like but who is this guy I
kind of know what he's saying but the
where there's like two but I don't have
two voices but I am constantly looking
to tell a joke at all times and it is a
defense mechanism I learned as a child
it is what I want to ask you guys is do
you hear your inner voice like when you
have a thought I'm sorry do you hear
your thoughts play out as a voice in
your head or do you just have abstract
thoughts does that make sense because
apparently there's two types of people
one that
um I can hear the thoughts and one that
don't hear thoughts I personally I don't
hear thoughts I have abstract thoughts
and ideas but I don't hear myself saying
them meaning there yeah but people some
people do hear a voice I don't know I'm
talking so much that I couldn't possibly
it just comes out like I think of
something and I say it immediately
that's when I got good at comedy though
honestly when I used to like hold back I
wasn't I would miss timing and stuff
interesting but you don't have a voice
either I don't think I do I'll try to
pay attention whatever it becomes
phrenic I'm scared no it's either you do
or you don't if what people that do very
are very shortly yeah that they have a
voice yeah
like Bobby does he's like I hear my
thoughts do you ever
talk do you guys talk out loud to
yourself when you're alone
I used to do this thing as a teenager
where if I would have a thought I would
say it out loud to see what it sounded
like if I were to hear myself say it
because I would have intrusive thoughts
so I would say that loud I'd be like
that sounds so dumb if you were like if
you were to remember voice moment that
would be cool right you wouldn't know
that you sound crazy if you say
something right like to
because sometimes it's easy to believe
your intrusive thoughts but if you say
them out loud you're like oh my God wait
that's a really good that's a great
exercise I feel like I I never used to
talk to myself like the thought of
people talking themselves I felt like
was like hacky and weird and I'm like
you don't really do they couldn't
possibly do that but then I've like kind
of started to do it and I actually
really am into it and sometimes I'll
film myself a video like that's just for
me just for my records like okay Esther
like here's this and like talk to myself
is that narcissistic
that's what that's what athletes do
really yeah like before a race you have
to like Envision everything from start
to finish and you have to like tell
yourself in the mirror every day like
you are this like just affirmations I
think that's what it is it's obvious
mirror mirror work yeah mirror work I
um
sort of talk to myself in the sense that
I know Todd has stopped listening but I
don't care like I just must talk like it
just must come out of me or okay but so
then could you talk if you know you're
in a room by yourself could you talk to
yourself
I could like sometimes like if I'm mad
like I think if I have like heightened
if I'm mad at myself I would probably
like
sit but then I have to try to like
change it you know like yeah something
nice or whatever but it is like I mean
I'll do the mirror work but I mean I
definitely am like this is a little not
it's like cheesy it's cheesy but I'll
just
keep doing it until it works yeah I it's
it's almost like you have to sort of
forget how cheesy and self-conscious you
should feel about it yeah and then and
just embrace it and be like wait well
this is a helpful free tool at my
disposal I might as well use it
um
but doesn't that guy look familiar like
someone help me he looks so much like
someone but what's this what type of
celebrity is this I don't know is it a
girl boy I don't know I'm thinking it's
a guy but that's like Adam Powell a
little bit too but I already Googled he
doesn't have a brother
the biggest hint to me is this guy says
he's friends with a lot of comedians
he's like a skinny Holly
and he was Heavy he was heavier he talks
a lot about how he lost weight
oh what if he's friends would just [ __ ]
don't mess with Carlos and wait yeah
he got all serious formal well if that
was true wouldn't he be out by one of
those comedians
unless these comedy look comedians don't
[ __ ] consume other people's content
like can we be real about Comedians and
first of all you can blow up on
Instagram and your comedian friends
could be like
comedians that have never been paid for
a spot or something too right people we
don't know people latch on to what
you're doing it's not necessarily like
he didn't get successful on Tick Tock
because like a famous person shared his
thing no totally right like it's like he
could just have been like he could be
friends with the people that like do the
mattress comedy what's mattress comedy
you know where they could just be doing
it off of a mattress on the street you
know they're always like in like a
garage or something during comedy and
ever in the audience's other Comics
going ha ha
to their jokes honestly that's generous
I feel like it opened mics in my day
nobody did that even I know that's how
we got good
so Esther what is this stuff athletic
greens is this magical special healthy
powder that you take in the morning and
it literally has all of the vitamins and
minerals and nutrients you need so you
don't have to like be in a rat race of
trying to eat the right salad and
veggies and [ __ ] like [ __ ] that I'm
eating pizza and athletic greens
I don't get my day started without it I
put it in I love to drink it with cold
water I use my matcha stirrer and I take
it down to hatch it makes me feel so
good and ready to face the day and I
never have to stop to think about do I
need
three salads to make up for you know my
vitamin and mineral needs for the day
you just chug that baby it tastes
delicious you feel good you feel healthy
you got to worry about nothing
everything else after that is a bonus
it's also lifestyle friendly so whether
you eat keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten-free
it contains less than one gram of sugar
no GMOs No nasty chemicals or artificial
anything while still tasting pretty good
and it's all in one it's all there all
the the 75 vitamins and minerals you
need in one place and athletic greens
has over seven thousand five star
reviews and it's recommended by
professional athletes and right now it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into the
flu and cold season it's just one scoop
in a cup of water every day that's it no
need for a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticreens.com Tuesday again that is
athleticreens.com Tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
Esther you ship a lot you're a shipper
yes I'm a business woman all of us here
you ship station because we all have our
own kind of like small businesses and so
shipstation has been extremely important
and valuable in that process for me and
shipstation works with all of your
favorite places to sell online including
Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more you can
manage your order from one simple
dashboard automate routine shipping
tasks print shipping labels and easily
compare rates and delivery times to
optimize every shipment and let's not
forget like it is about to be the
holiday season which is really hectic so
you're going to want to make these
processes as easy and as streamlined as
possible and that's why shipstation is
such a good choice also I just feel like
I want all my sluggies to get rich guys
the internet exists it's time for you to
start your own business create your own
things
Etsy all these things are real okay get
shipstation to help with your small
businesses get rich with us let's do it
over a hundred thirty thousand companies
have grown their e-commerce businesses
with ship station and 98 of companies
that stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life that's a
really big deal you guys this holiday
season give yourself the gift of
stress-free holiday shipping use promo
code trash Tuesday today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code trash Tuesday
he looks like yeah I'm getting Adam
Polly what about John well no John
gabrison just thinking because Adam
Polly and him have that show yeah Adam
Pally is this an awkward time to say
that John gabras is in my movie no
everyone is I can't it's not like the
only awkward thing will be if you like
is are you trying to find out who it is
so you can cast it in the movie as your
co-host or female co-host
foreign
no no I'm not even listen I don't want
to be in your movie I just want to let
you know how
how it is like who's who of everyone
I've ever met isn't I ca I keep bumping
into people like oh I know you I'm
actually an Esther's movie if there was
a role for you it would be I don't care
there's a lot of guys
oh there's a lot of guys yeah the male
gays the male gays she's trying to make
a hit guys
um no I don't want to be in your [ __ ]
movie
laughs
so yeah that's my new mystery man he has
nice eyes oh God Carlos is really
starting to come into His
homosexuality today
we were on bad friends earlier and he
kind of came out what come out I just
told the story about how I took Molly
and a casting director like try to hook
up with me in a bed oh really what
happened Esther pretending like she's
never heard the story no I don't know
like she hasn't been in bed with a
casting director sorry I don't that's
not true it's not true it's not true
it's not true first of all casting
directors don't have that power Oh I
thought I have no interest in you
physically
Andrew has taught me the same thing he
was like they don't have power it's okay
Carla
we but
why were you in a bed with someone like
Molly they haven't done Molly they
haven't done Molly they don't understand
oh really it's like a bedroom where
people were doing like drugs and that's
where the Molly was and it just hit me
really hard and then you're just sitting
on a bed then you're laying on a bed not
till our live show
I have to say though like that sounds so
[ __ ] fun to me to just be in a
bedroom with a group of people and
you're all doing drugs and are happy I
think everyone making out that's what
I've been longing for no I wasn't I've
had some like weird I had like a um back
in Santa Fe I guess it was ecstasy it
was like before Molly it was and we
would we pulled like my friend's like
mattress onto the floor and then we were
all like just rolling really hard but
there was just one married couple and it
just threw everything off because
everyone was kind of making out and I
was like I don't want to make out with
your husband I don't care if you guys
are open I just don't want to make up
with your husband because we're good
with friends we were all friends we were
all like worked at the same bar and
stuff so it was just like I'm not making
out with your husband first of all I
don't want to make out with your husband
but then second of all I we're gonna get
off the the Ecstasy at some point and
then I'm just gonna be the girl that
made out with your [ __ ] husband we
that is such a fascinating concept to me
right now because I'm like
would you if someone wanted you to make
out with her husband I'm like would I I
don't I don't want I don't know no I
don't want I don't like I'm like all for
like Polly everything there's actually
these like [ __ ] adorable poly girls
that come to my shows when I go to
Irvine all the time they're so cute and
it was but I want to get to the bottom
of they were telling me like one of them
like I was like did you break up with
the girl that were in a threat pool and
the one girl's like I broke up with
another girls like I didn't break up
with her
and I'm like this is messy [ __ ] and
I'm like why is your [ __ ] she goes the
girl had such a good she goes because
she won't come to the show with us I was
like good girl that's right but it's
like they're sluggies what's up are poly
slugs wait
um wait a second was she asking you to
make out with her husband or was he yeah
other girls make out with him well
you know that's a good question it's
just kind of we were all kind of like
wandering around this living room you
know like rolling around in these
mattresses and then
he just became one of the people that
was in front of me leaning in because
everyone was kind of maybe he's got you
out it sounds like that yeah yeah
because it wasn't her telling me to do
it but I was like even though I was like
figuring they were probably open because
they're doing Molly with all of us or
doing Ecstasy but it just was like I
just don't want to be
like I If You're Polly if you're in a
relationship like God bless you Shalom
but it just it like I just don't want to
be involved in it I don't want to be
involved in it yeah that seems sticky I
don't want to be in a sticky sitch
yeah that that feeling of dread even
when I drink alcohol is like something
that is like it's no bigger hell in my
mind than feeling like what did I say
what did I do who did I do it did I [ __ ]
someone's husband yeah that's it's
always at an even now that even when I
have a drink or two the next morning
that I feel that same dread and I know
what I did I know but that feeling of
like what the [ __ ] did I do dude I would
black out every time so I was like I
would wake up in the morning like ah
what did I do and like if my phone
wasn't broken into two [ __ ] pieces I
would always wake up my phone to be in
two different rooms with the flip phones
it was like such a hell thank God I quit
drinking before iPhones came out is that
crazy that's how long ago drinking but I
mean I would have been just breaking a
computer every night I would just been
smashing a [ __ ] computer every night
and like but if my phone was still with
us I would like just have to like text
everyone sorry like I'd have to be like
I'm sorry I don't know what I did but I
would just wake up with this kill in
this dread just like what did I do same
and I before I would leave the house I
would always take six shots of Jack
Daniels yeah or even leaving the house
because I didn't have a lot of money
yeah you're not you don't have money to
go to the club so you would get almost
as close to blackout as you could before
leaving the house bring the bottle drink
more in the Park oh my God my personal
stuff
[Music]
yeah so it was like a race and I think
that 2 A.M cut off or 1 30 last call
really makes it more urgent yes oh my
god when they say last call I'd be like
shot exactly oh it's everyone shots like
oh my God they're gonna end I would wake
up reaching for more alcohol I was like
had to keep going going going I think it
makes it more dangerous to have like a
cut off time because then people start
to really feel like I gotta get as much
in and then they you know they do and
then we all black out and then you're
[ __ ] blacked out bottomless I'm
making out with a [ __ ] cockroach in a
[ __ ] Alleyway you know I once had a
sleepover cockroach oh my God this is so
sad this is how you relate to it I once
had a sleepover with a famous model
and
um she's better now but what is that
mean but I never had seen anything like
this we woke up in the bed in the hotel
room and she rolled over
and grabbed a bottle and drank it yeah
because you get the shakes if you don't
yeah whatever we used to call it um we
call Jack Daniel's OJ so we'd be like
past the OJ right so it's like in the
morning but wouldn't that like make you
so like the thought of that makes me so
less sick it's the hair of the dog it's
coming down that's what that means it's
because you're I don't know what can you
look up why it's called hair of the dog
but it's like you when you're already
like drunk like you're still [ __ ] up
it's still in your system but you're
like not in a good place with it
something you drink more of it and
you're chill you're good right so when
you go on Benders it's best that you
just don't stop because if you stop then
you have hours of feeling like [ __ ]
unless you have an IV nurse but if your
IV nurse dies
and this is how I lost five years of my
20s a shortening of hair of the dot wait
what a shortening of hair of the dog
that bit you a folk remedy for rabies
like placing hair from the dog that
bites onto the wound this is oh it's um
it's by taking the thing that you think
is making you sick yeah actually
remedying it with the taking the hair of
the dog to treat the rabies bite is the
same as drinking Jack Daniels to flex
your to avoid The Hangover so basically
a bender you should be drinking the
whole time and then what happens when
you want to stop the when you have to
stop your Bender oh is it hard as a
spinner to be asking about banners
I mean the week after I'd say like now
if I have a good night of drinking it
takes me about a week to recover I could
never ever drink again anxious a
depressed dark just like I have night
sweats it's horrible it's horrible
coming out from like a big night of
drinking now for me wait Annie can you
tell me why would you never drink I will
never ever hang over again I will never
deal with again I get just like if I
don't sleep I get a hangover like I
stopped my voice loss from um skank
Festival from last week but I mean that
wasn't sober I was sober let's just say
I had some AAA meetings in the bathroom
stall if you know what I mean my sponsor
was theirs I said last time man wait a
second dude
I was like oh my sponsored manscape I
hung out with manscape dude it was so
fun manscape was came out do you get
hangovers from doing like acid or
shrooms is there like a come down it's
just I don't sleep well so I'm just
tired but I may be dehydrated why don't
you sleep well cause I'm [ __ ] because
they act like uppers I'm going nuts yeah
you're like up for it's like
acid you could be on for like 11 hours
oh God I had so much fun we I missed the
episode where you talked about it like
it it what was acid like it was so fun I
was laughing we just had so much [ __ ]
fun I can't even believe it I was
telling them they [ __ ] bumped me on
the show and I was like this is not the
time to bump me I have time to this
perfectly I was like oh my God I was
like starting to trip on acid on stage I
was like oh God it was crazy like acid
before yes because I timed it up because
I wanted to get [ __ ] up all day so the
fun part about festivals I think is like
the Hang right also doing the shows but
you just can't wait till your show's
over to get all [ __ ] up because it's
fun it's like tripping with all my
friends it was all my friends from like
New York it was people I hadn't seen in
years Mike Cannon Mike Feeney Scott
Chaplin like it was just my Sean Patton
just like these people that I like we
were like in the [ __ ] trenches
together back in the day and just like
so many jokes so fun and then like Josh
Potter was there and like hormones from
the comedies just like so many people it
was just like and then I met like Joey
Avery is my new boy like I just I it
just was like and Kyle I heard and Kyle
Kyle wasn't allowed to end was Kyle uh
tripping on acid as well
um Kyle was yeah he was on actually he
was on Molly and nobody else he seems
like a cocaine guy he was on coke yeah
um Todd was there obviously but it was
just like it like every room I walked
into was so fun
it was so [ __ ] fun it was just like
the fans were so nice I was saying this
on the last episode I don't know if
it'll stay in or we'll just put it in
here but
it's like the skank Fest fans you think
are gonna be like the most misogynistic
scumbat like they were Angels like it
was like safe fun environment and these
angels they were so good it was so fun
Kim Kong it was like fist fighting
people in a [ __ ] ring it was crazy
some girl was like beating every girl's
ass there was like one skank Fest girl
that's just like the [ __ ] most ripped
like thick Heavy Muscle this doesn't
sound Angelic it was Angelic it was I
don't know how to explain it hell and
he's housing
examples wait
um would you do acid in like a non-like
festival situation is the kind of thing
you would ever like do at home or is
that pointless at home but just like I
mean I guess she's asking for herself
yes I am projecting here like or how is
it no we're gonna do we'll do acid
together what does it do to you she's
like I'm sorry I actually cast John
gabras and then my ass doing acid what
do you like how how does it I know Dave
gets so mad at me when I ask these
questions and if anyone else is getting
annoyed I'm sorry but like how does it
compare to like that's so sad that Dave
has made you so paranoid that you
apologize to an audience that's not even
here yet well he's just like act like
you've been there shut up everyone
doesn't need to know you're high no we
like that no we like it we like that
you're it's funny that you're like this
weird little drug prude
tell me how does it compare here to the
other drugs which ones have you done
mushrooms now I did like a little bit of
mushrooms but it wasn't
that a a lot of mushrooms there was I
was in a hoodie with sunglasses on one
point just like
so naturally over half of women will
experience hair thinning in their
lifetime I'm one of them
when I turned 30 my hair just started
falling off my head at a really rapid
rate I was getting really desperate so
when I found neutrophil and what I love
about neutrophil is this it doesn't
promise to be an overnight fix it's
something that you take every day and
really really good ingredients do like
these are just good vitamins yeah and
they're like out to they want to
normalize hair loss they want to
normalize hair thinning and make it
normal and it's such a thing that maybe
women we never really talk about it like
the focus is always on like you know men
like like male pattern baldness and
whatnot Carlos is always stealing the
show but we experience something similar
go ahead but even all the mommy sluggies
too like I know all the like moms was
the hair a lot a lot of women in
pregnancy lose their hair it's like I
have to say it's women have dealing with
hair thinning has always been a very
private conversation in my life like
it's something I've always talked about
with my mom and my sister and I never
see people like or I never even just see
it out in the world and that's why it is
so cool neutral does want to normalize
is women openly discussing that their
hair is thinning and it's something that
they want to fix and because neutrophil
offers a solution that's actually just
healthy and based on like not gimmicks
I'm really proud that they're our
sponsor and hair thinning is a reality
for millions of women yet most are
reluctant like you said to discuss it
neutrival is a clinically effective
natural supplement brand and so we want
and to invite you guys to check out shed
the silence.com because let's talk about
it right like if your hair story could
help another woman I think we should all
join the conversation at
shedthesilence.com that's shed the
silence.com
but acid is like are you saying dolphin
assisted suicide a dolphin assisted
birth have you heard oh birth I don't
know I just heard that much but that's
so funny yeah we gotta knock you up now
that I know about this you've got to
have a kid no I've actually been uh um
thinking about it and I not to like
announce it the world because I know
that everyone will be looking maybe your
sperm donor but I am like looking into
doing it by myself and I am thinking I
have been really careful about who I
think I want like my criteria for sperm
donors well if you want to loosen up
that puss uh why don't you start by
popping out one of my embryos oh my God
a bunch of loose in that vajazzle up me
if you're gonna carry one of hers you'll
take one of mine as well at the same
time
we don't think they're gonna be able to
have one wait can you do that the baby
the embryo is bigger than Esther wait is
that possible if she had an embryo
frozen embryo and I put two embryos
inside oh my God that would be so cute
that's what I would love to go in on a
surrogate with someone and do that well
then she's so Jewish she wants half off
yeah
but then I would have to like require
that I get 100 custody that you can be
like um Auntie mom like you know do you
know you'll like spoil them so you can
keep mine wait are you finally we got
someone to raise our kids that's been
the whole problem
what is your criteria in terms of is it
do you want someone you know or a
stranger that's been the biggest con uh
back and forth I've been going through
and I would like I want to know the
nature of somebody who they are if
they're good like inherently good when I
talked to the doctor Dr Moosa shout out
he's great but he was more like it
doesn't matter he's like I have three
kids and all are like completely
different like the gamble the genetic
gamble like it was just you just never
really know like you could like have a
baby with the most like Pious Saint and
have like you know what I mean did you
just hear pie
but I heard strawberry rhubarb on my
head of you but yeah like I think I have
some of what I think I want
you know I have an idea why don't Esther
why don't you list all of the people in
your movie and she can pick one do we
have enough time Bobby do we have enough
time
well is there anyone that you know
that's like on the consideration can you
tell us or no I don't want to say yet
but I have like asked certain people
like hey like would you consider this
and they'd be like yeah that sounds cool
they want to [ __ ] you no we don't we're
not going to bang it out they think
they're gonna get to [ __ ] you no Lila
nobody's gonna be like yes I wanna have
a kid with you and not get to [ __ ] you
you're really hot for that these are
guys I usually don't uh who not usually
these are guys who don't necessarily
want children right that's probably the
but they fit the criteria of what I want
like I like uh
you know like I like a good country boy
I like uh
[Laughter]
he wants to have a section that's so
mean oh yeah to just carry the baby but
not do this so it's like the ultimate
cocktail yeah I don't know I don't want
to like bang it out traditionally with
them no like I don't want to have sex
with anybody like any of my spirit you
know what Theo's big fat ass image in
your legs
um
big ass I really thought about this
because everyone keeps pitting me and
Theo like together and I I really have I
think about this all the time and I just
don't catch a Vibe
but we do think he really has a crush on
you or we think he's kind of doing a bit
easier really I think he has a crush on
you he's gonna be fun it would be like
the type of worshiping that Theo would
do to you would be so hard he absolutely
does not like we have like our Vibe like
off camera is very like sibling love I
love Theo I love him you [ __ ] your
brother though which it is a good point
that for you is very blurry that is
they're the only one that that's weird
tricky would you consider an athlete's
sperm not even financially just like
um not even financially the fact that
she had just the genetics it seems like
someone else has creating an athlete is
not number one on my priority because
you are traumatized yeah it's like
there's so many it's nice like that
you're a specimen okay five yeah I have
a question where we know the apocalypse
is nigh this is hypothetical we know the
apocalypse is nigh we have
um we know that in 10 years
we there's gonna be not ten years 15
years there's going to be
crazy everything is going to be insane
we're going to be all fending for our
lives do you want to have a kid you have
to have a kid
your kid will be 14 years old at the
point do you want them to be hot
do you want them to be athletic or do
you want them to be smart which is going
to survive and help you you go with
smart smart yeah crafty crafty little
Savvy little thing I was thinking
probably strong hot hot people always
win
you're right right they're pretty
privilege you can sell them off you can
sell them off make some money
right so I would say a strong is
probably third I think I hot would be
second manipulate manipulate ones can
manipulate but then does does Evan
anyone looking at Beauties anyone's dick
or [ __ ] wet when there's a [ __ ] it's
survival is is on the line I don't think
so I guess you're right because for
myself I would prioritize being smart
but I when I think of my kid I'm like
scared it's just gonna if it it's gonna
be so weak
your neck problems yeah is it banana
break time
[Music]
my dream is if you birthday
and in 10 years he looks like Little
Hercules like you have you seen that kid
who's just so ripped and everyone's like
and then everyone's like what do your
parents look like and then it's you and
Dave that's so cute you got to see
Little Hercules yeah I think there's you
could be good at disciplining like yeah
that's just discipline you could just
make your kid and train them to work out
all the time oh you're right
look I want that to be your baby okay it
looks grown up wait it looks like me and
Dave's baby already the face and the
hair no neck up
he's so cute he was obviously related as
a freaking child yeah it's like does
seem a little child abused definitely
yeah it's so cute did he not grow at all
though look how not ripped he is now oh
because it's banana break I want to tell
you guys what I've been doing probably
five nights a week I take my bananas put
it in between your legs you shake it
around
you're disgusting [ __ ] no not all I got
on your movie I gotta Play Your Banana
very nice no I put it in the freezer
I take it out I put it in a blender I'm
such a hack it's like no no no it's so
good it's so good I make like a fake
Frosty I do we all have done that I know
but it's important almond milk yes cocoa
powder uh-huh vanilla salt a lot and
it's a chocolate salty drink and it's so
[ __ ] good and I just want everyone to
know that just because I don't eat my
banana here doesn't mean I'm not
hoarding doesn't mean I'm not hoarding
it in between my legs
for you to try to play this you just
figured out about banana I know it is
sad but remember I had really of not
that much of a childhood
I mean I didn't need it it was during my
you know you never went like
no sugar you never want no sugar that's
the thing you never went no natural no
artificial sugar
until recently until Carlos started
slapping things out of your head right
usually I don't incorporate fruit into
desserts you were you were gummy bears
and dye color like red five colored uh
sprinkles yeah a lot of like gummy worms
yeah I would like I just had like Esther
always like went to a place where they
had candy and bulk and like made a bag
for herself yes I feel like a bag yes
I've known you very long we have this
place called The Sweet Factory at Old
Orchard Mall and the thing is you don't
think I've known you because and all of
your bodies of work I've never been in
them so it doesn't look like even on me
I mean one would argue you are a large
part of the biggest body of work that I
don't want to be your biggest bottle
I know that was your your uh your um new
girl what's your biggest body
what do you think's a hot when when he
thinks the hottest you've ever been what
age is it now now totally and I'm only
mentally ever going to believe that I'm
always going to be at my hottest like
I'm not I'm never because I've done that
thing where you see it accidentally see
a selfie of yourself like five years ago
and you're like oh no there's
differences I don't like them and I've
just decided like never again I'm not
looking I'm happy with what I look like
now and moving forward period end of
story I feel like we all I like I when I
actually feel like a little bit
I want to like love myself at every
phase of my life but I think I've gotten
way hotter you are hot like if you look
back on like yeah you have gotten hotter
I would because I was always trying to
like hide being attractive at all like I
never wanted to be like that is a real
thing okay so
and I feel like you too even but I feel
like for us because of doing stand-up
don't you feel like you were told like
you can't like your looks will distract
from the comedy so you like you could
never be feminine and like be feel
pretty and stuff Rachel Feinstein had a
joke about it where she's like why do
female comedians have to dress like one
of the Beastie Boys
[ __ ] that's good she was at skank fast
is she in the movie oh she was so funny
everyone was so good
um I think um I just started wearing
sleeveless shirts on tigerbelly this
year
maybe once in the last like one other
time in the last like seven eight years
just in time to have a shoulder injury
exactly what do you think it's the same
it's the same um idea that you have
about trying to like I don't know I just
felt like maybe
um people would like you just don't
wanna you want people to listen to you
and want to talk to you but I had fake
tits for a while too so more and more so
that I wanted to like cover up always
wear like sweatshirts yeah when I did
the podcast I don't know why maybe
subconsciously I felt the same way you
guys did
um where I was like no I can't be a hot
like chick next to Bobby I would just be
like nah yeah whatever this is maybe
[ __ ] up to say but I also feel like
when you're in your 20s it's like
I I just have this Vision that like
Predators want to like rape you and when
you're in your 30s like predators are
like oh she's old now so I'm like okay I
can just be myself and be hot and
predators don't be as interested in
raping me how does that well you that
looks so young until like recently and
not and you still look young but you
look like a like a legal age now like
you look 18 now and before he looks so
young like for you to be you would have
looked like me as like my little baby
[ __ ] face like my fortune on like
backless shirts like walking if I looked
older than you look now then
so you dressing sexy as a kid would have
been like yeah as a 20 year old it'd be
pulling in too many pedophiles
I know you are a good bait we should put
you on the end of a hook throw you at
the Laugh Factory
I know who's coming in first coming in
first then coming in hot Kyle had a lot
to say honestly I miss Kyle I want to
meet Kyle I gotta say like let's have a
threesome me one Kyle
Carlos is like what about me
you're Out Boy
oh I got sleepy Esther would you really
know how to eat a [ __ ] if it was in
front of you
well you got to put a gummy worm in it
she'll celebrate on up like how do you
think your [ __ ] eating skills would
fare
I think good really where would you
start and how would you do it oh my God
practice Yeah heavy practice
should we do that we would get
demonetized oh really we ate out papayas
look Pete's like we could let it pass
let us do it Daddy we did on the live
we'll do it alive all right we should
have who's like really good eating [ __ ]
and I'm not allowing you Carlos I said I
don't think it's me I definitely [ __ ]
say it but it's like you're going to
it's gonna be so annoying I don't want
it to be you we need someone that's like
known as a good [ __ ]
eat now and get hurt don't try to make
this the Carla show on bad friends maybe
not wait we call its ex-wife
her number is disconnected
it doesn't exist wait but do you this
now let's talk to the guys do you think
that you're good at it Carlos I think
I'm good at it because girls have told
me I'm good at it so I'm believing them
and they come like that's literally why
did I squirt into your uvula like a like
a punching bag you actually was going
down on an escort like 10 years ago oh
my God I love you for that she squirted
but I'm pretty sure it was pee and it
went all into my mouth and I drank a
little bit of it and I was like that's
so salty squirt is mostly is it like a
pickleback it was at a really cool hotel
downtown where they shot Interstellar so
when I'm watching her Stellar I'm always
like escort
it's so funny to make an escort come
that's so like did you get a discount
I made an escort come once actually
after the naughty show we drove back
from Santa Barbara Esther that night I
saw an escort like at three in the
morning in Hollywood and I made her come
and she said I didn't have to pay her
the 300 and she was like like a hot 40
year old oh Carlos this is so romantic I
it really is Big deals for me it was
right next to the W Hotel so it was cool
scenery you're a real man aren't you
oh my God
I like how it's like a cinematic moment
timer with an escort why because he's
making it up like a scrub
making it up
back to you Esther you think you're you
think you you're good at it you think
you'd be good yeah don't you think any
woman who's interested in it would be
good just like isn't any guy and who's
interested in giving a [ __ ] good at
that I don't think so
why did you get it personally yeah well
just being interested in a subject
doesn't make you correct no I mean
interested in wanting to do it like
passion but you could get nervous
because you're like in your head wanting
to be really good at it right yeah right
okay true for instance like I don't
think I'd be good at it with those lips
[ __ ]
I mean here's the thing I saw an olive
into the mouth
I was like is that squirt because I
think that wanting to do it is not
enough because I've been with men who
really obviously are like oh that's the
worst thing they try so hard and you
they it's just like this is they're just
missing and you have to like explain to
them and then it hurts their feelings
because they like it they have in their
head that they're good at it right and
then so you just have to be like
I yeah uh that's the worst I actually
think I've never had a bad version of
that
really when a guy is just so thirsty and
he's like I'm so I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this I'm gonna do this and do this and
then you finally do and then there's
like and they're like they're like it's
a little too not soft yeah
can you not be so [ __ ] I had a
boyfriend in college that was so good at
eating [ __ ] that it's like it's
actually insane he was so good he's like
married with kids and that's why I can't
have him like on the show but I mean
maybe his wife would actually probably
were you gonna invite him to eat our
[ __ ]
that's where I was going with this he
could show us how to eat girls out it
was crazy like we were like I was like
failing out of college like we were just
like not feeling out of college we're
just like we didn't go to class oh my
God it was crazy we'd be like about to
leave and he would just be like start
eating me out again I'm like I I'm like
you're failing out of college because
you were getting I mean I was probably
gonna fail it anyway but he saved me the
humiliation of like failing from my own
brain
damn that is so hot it was so he was
really a talented boy I would love to
like have my life fall apart just
because I was just like getting it good
you look like you got [ __ ] out of
college for getting you now doesn't she
have like I just got eaten out for a
while outfit on
[Laughter]
I'm in an eat out mood
I go let's go to In and Out that is a
mood though sometimes I just want to be
fingered or ate out and I really don't
want to do anything else oh totally oh
yeah no I talked about it I think the
last episode I had a guy and my phone is
under mouth he would just give me now
Annie you are a [ __ ] this is a g you are
a feminist well some guys are just like
so their ego is so attached to making
people to making women come that they
like
they don't care or they're like whatever
or maybe they have like [ __ ] up dicks
or something like it didn't Harvey
Weinstein not to be like carving
Weinstein's like we miss you buddy
where you been Connie's being mean to
you
um oh and I'm like how Connie is
speaking to you
um but like I want to go down on a chick
and then have her be like that was
terrible Todd likes lesbo porn so but he
doesn't but Todd is so monogamous that I
don't think he would like let me eat a
girl out really no yeah
but I don't want to I just want my Todd
I don't want anyone else is that okay
that's totally yeah all of you sex
fiends
I just I just can't I'm just surprised
at how like you the lack of confidence
you guys have in your skills like don't
you think that because you've been eaten
out and because you know what feels I
think I could do it and I think maybe
pressure like the girl would have to let
me know because I do there is like um
you know when guys do like the
or they do like a light sucking like I
don't want a strong suck I don't either
and there has to be like it has to be a
variety it can't just be the one thing
yeah but there's like the pressure and
then the tongue like the flat part of
the tongue what about getting fingered
at the same time oh that's it Heaven
it's everything especially from the back
on all fours if you just tap all three
it's like that's like the best ever
tap all three yeah because you get your
um [ __ ] like rub and then you get
eight out and then someone's fingering
you at the same time it's the best how
many people are there how is the family
room it's a family reunion
wait a second you've not had that but
you're on all fours Carlos here you're
on all four Carlos hey Carlos sure let
me try it on you yeah I'm gonna eat you
out from the back okay I have a spot
about to cancel my spot why to get eaten
out maybe I'll make Todd eat me out in
the basement
oh my God
[Laughter]
but also like the tucked in shirt is so
funny
face down ass up please okay yeah Arch
the back a little bit more
the [ __ ] is going to be approximately
right here so you're gonna have a finger
in the outside and we're just rubbing
around and then okay finger in the eyes
wow that's my phone um oh sorry sorry
finger in the ass right
um finger on the [ __ ] right
right whoa I don't think I've done that
so you do this to the [ __ ] right sorry
you do this to the [ __ ] you rub the
[ __ ] and then you're just
right
Carlos okay did you come
oh he's curling over he's coming he has
a boner
he is not that's like always what I
asked for oh wait that's so smart to ask
but it's always what I asked for I'm
like is this on the menu I wrote that
right when guys are this is I do love
Todd but
yeah but I used to love in dirty talk
when guys would be like I'm gonna eat
your [ __ ] from behind even though I
don't it's not really like it I don't
find it to be the best yeah I've never
done I don't find it to be the best
because we're lazy [ __ ] which like I
would much rather right I can't imagine
being allowed to wrap my legs around
kind of
trap the men
and um I think the live show should
definitely have some sort of
experimentation element our parents
cannot watch this time I think
experimenting is healthy for young women
got by the way my bush is so big right
now it's like so crazy it's so like I'll
just go to town and go look how long it
is I love that that's like next level
I'm trying to think of whether or not I
should grow my bush back but it's just
not happening he told me to he told me I
was like what do you want me to get done
I was like I'll do whatever you want
with my pubes he goes he goes I want you
to have a landing strip but I wanted to
go all the way up with your belly button
to my unibrow yeah
that is cute I want to do laser when do
we get our freelance oh yeah yeah laser
is really not expensive I know but I
want it I just want to have like a laser
sponsor yeah we should we should
cultivate that but it isn't that
expensive but you do have to keep going
back and it hurts loser sucks I like her
me getting our sponsor laser sucks
um I have an addiction to getting my
twin twin hair it's my shin hair is
Twist like only imagine Harris it is so
painful and itchy at the same time do
you guys try that I actually like have
some do we have any tweezers in the
house
I might have some in my purse yeah I
just like I feel like maybe someone can
pluck my nipples or something yeah but I
can't imagine yours are like coarse and
dark wait let's do that on there mine
are let's do the live show we'll grow
them out yeah all right let's grab our
nips mine I'm already there I'm already
there but how do we but we can't show
them
we'll just show a little blur or cover
the circle part yeah we can't blur
though do you think we could sell them
sell auctions sell our nipple hair oh my
God there's got to be a market for it of
course really I'm sure you could you
starting with you what's your bid I'm
not buying your nipple have it off Annie
if I want grab it off man oh assault I'm
gonna take it off on set oh wait wasn't
invited oh my god I didn't even get a
job as craft services
but you can put it on those like
microscope slides we don't need that
this girl just is Asian she don't have
the hair like us oh no I do oh you'd be
surprised you oh my God I can't wait to
show you I cannot wait to show you oh
yeah I got some good ones
I have so much padding hold on I have to
go through the full padding this is so
crazy how much smaller my boobs are than
this
I plucked recently I'll grow up
fancy you I saw a girl oh my God I saw a
girl oh I hope she's a slug a girl
driving down Lincoln Boulevard
she was mirrored down we're in traffic
stopped to the light plucking chin hairs
I was like if that is not the vibe you
know when you feel stray hair and you're
like it must be plucked now I will die I
will crash my car looking for tweezers I
don't care I have had that feeling I
have so gross I have this like one we
all have fun we all have one we're like
every so often I touch it and I'm like
it's back it's Gotta Go this [ __ ]
stray single hair and it really does
it's like there's a bug on me and I'm
looking it off me get it off and get it
off me like I can't it has to go yeah my
whole life is like really I I feel quite
the opposite I used to have these like
wiry white hairs just
pop out of nowhere in my body and I
would cry when they would fall off I get
really attached to them what because
they're wiry and thick like because when
her dad passed away and it's my dad
coming through me his gray hair
coming inside me
the way you're telling it though it's
like they're your friends and then you
miss them he is like this do you
remember you have a tattoo of this [ __ ]
Bobby had a skin tag he didn't want to
part ways with oh yeah I'm so glad I got
rid of my skin tag I look and I go what
was I thinking clinging to that thing I
don't miss it one day every once in a
while my hair does still grow and I go I
remember you I haven't had any like
stray hairs on my face yet but I can't
wait
I can't wait to keep them there I think
this is your topic is it I like it what
is it it's this it's basically
um
oh it's another Tick Tock look at that
I've been tricked I've been trick talked
into the trick talk I've been trick
talked into a ticket let's call this
segment trick time it's the whole show
let's all right we're gonna watch it
yeah let's do Tick Tock Corner trick
talk time to trick Annie
into not talking they're crazy about the
opposite of love is not hate it's
indifference the fact that he and his
girlfriend had to have a conversation
about removing you that's a compliment I
would never block someone that I'm
indifferent about and neither do men and
only black women that they're crazy
about the opposite of love is not so I
did bring this one up because obviously
it feels like a little bit of a possible
it's a reach but it's a reach for a win
as to my high school ex-boyfriend
blocking me he's scared of you that's a
restraining order it's different okay
this is not this is like his house
he's
worried about himself
I actually do think you're right but I
just wanted to share a possible idea why
don't you offer him a partner movie
it's kind of based on him
wait I think there is some truth to this
though because I'd say that if like for
me if I was really asking my boyfriend
never to speak to someone again it's
probably because I am she is poses the
biggest threat like I am so insecure
about it
um but I've been blocked I've been
blocked by my ex and
um when he got with his new chick
figured it was more a her thing and I
don't know he probably just like wanted
to be like respectful of her but I know
that she was definitely very worried
about me was it like just kind of out of
nowhere that you got blocked or were you
was it before you took the tits out
I really um I think it's because
um she was somebody who got in the
middle of our relationship and
um she was trying to
um so when we eventually broke up and
they got together
um she is a little bit of production I
think well they get scared because they
know that they're yeah what they did I
don't know what could happen but no um I
got blocked maybe like a week after him
and I had like a great talk we were just
like hey like like we were together for
four and a half years like let's stay
like let's stay cool not like best
friends but you know if we run into each
other hey what's up
and he was like I'm really proud of you
like love like great that to see you
like doing so well blah blah and it was
the next thing you know was like blocked
on all platforms that's yeah that's the
girl and I'm like yeah it's okay though
but because how long like how long ago
was that are you still blocked now yeah
I'm still blocked yeah they just forgot
but it's weird because like I checked
too I was like oh maybe it's just him
but then she blocked me off of
everything I'm like I'm not actively
like
searching or like wanting to partake
like we're broken up I broke up with him
like what are you doing yeah and it's it
sucks too for her especially it's like
that doesn't really solve the problem
with the problem you know yeah it will
help though because you can like get out
of you can you get over people when you
don't see them like if you have to keep
seeing them it is kind of like yeah but
if you have to force someone to do that
he cheated she she was they were in a
relationship and then she got him while
they were dating so it's like it was
overlap so yeah there was it was already
about I'm not saying they're right
because that's like a shitty way to
start a relationship but it's just like
it's just if you can block someone then
you eventually
will forget about them because they're
just gone from here right and then you
can't look at them because I had to do
that I blocked my exes for a little bit
and then they're not [ __ ] now I don't
care now okay but my argument to that
would be that
if you have to
Force someone to block someone like it's
already a bad situation
because they [ __ ] cheated so it's
like you know what I mean it's like yeah
he isn't trustworthy I just I know I
think he is though and he was really
into her and I had a talk with her
saying like hey like beep beep like this
relationship is over I understand there
was like uh what do you call it uh
overlap yeah but I'm like I am not
interested in him and getting back with
him like can everything just be cool and
she
she did but sometimes girls want there
to be that like that makes their man
hotter like right if she you know it's
like she wants to think that you are
maybe like pining over him or something
like that because I've had that too with
an experts like
the girl that he ended up with was like
so harsh and crazy to me and I'm like I
don't want him like he is yours it's
fine she was just pretending that you
liked him yeah herself feel good yes a
hundred percent I was like dude there's
no fight here like right he's yours but
she wanted there to be a fight so bad
and then the next guy she dated she
stole him from a girl too oh that's like
her okay so here's where I think the for
me at least I needed to have that talk
with her because him and I were still
living together and so I thought it was
just the correct thing to do to be like
yo he's not coming here we're not
hooking up there's no vibe we're
breaking up the boxes are packed
um but I don't know like I just think
that
um that was so unnecessary only because
it's like I'm not after him home girl
like I'm like that chapter is closed I
stayed friends with an ex and X I dated
and I was like much much younger and we
were like in our late 30s now and every
time we he like recalls his past he
always talks about
cheating on me
and while we were in a relationship it's
actually so funny though like we were
together for like four three four years
and I never thought he cheated on me I
was so sure that this person I was like
no like we live together like I know
wouldn't you just rather not know I'm
like just lied about it forever like
because it [ __ ] with my head I'm like
oh that makes you not just other people
it makes me not trust myself and my
intuition because I'm like how did I
just go to sleep at night thinking this
boy loves me so much all the while he
was literally like he couldn't stop
[ __ ] others I'm always so shocked
when I find someone shooting my mom was
like oh what like I know I just because
I feel like trust is a choice that you
you just like decide to trust people and
that's just how I've always looked at it
so I never like I'm never snooping for
bad things like I always I'm like if
I've gone into a guy's phone it's like
for some other reason and then I'm like
oh my God what you're cheating on me but
that because of because of things like
that and because of people coming
forward and telling me that type of
information in I've that's all I do
Snoop yeah like I don't respect people's
privacy yeah see I didn't have the
person tell me after it was just like
after the breakup everyone else just
assumed I knew and I'm like oh that is
okay but and I even then I was like I
don't think that's true but I'm looking
back I'm like in high school my my
teacher told me like oh that must be so
hard for Yoda I was like what
it's no clue no they were all banging us
except I well I do want to say one other
thing about the blocking video which is
like
it is and I have like a more toxic
interpretation of it than yours which I
really liked of like it's for you to not
see them but it is a little bit like of
a flex if someone blocks you yeah
because it's like oh I guess like I'm
just too much for you to handle sorry I
think so I get a giggle out of it if
someone like well I I've no but I've
been blocked by Like Girls when girls
block me it's like they're like you
don't get access to me but then I'm like
I will very fast be over you like the
minute I go like oh you're not like yeah
you're not your Instagram's not even fun
like it's not like you're like doing
funny things that I'm like it's like oh
I don't get to see the flyer of the show
you're on right it's like they're not
punishing you well what I find is
whenever I do have like that dark
Instinct where I'm like I just don't
like this person I want to block them
like it is a it always comes from a
place of having no control and having no
ability to like Express or do anything
so it's like the last resort and I I try
to never do it but like it comes from a
place of weakness it's like I'm just so
mad there's nothing else I can do I'm
gonna block them like it's not good 100
even the way I was saying it like where
it's like I can't trust myself to not go
on your
page you know like I have like an
addiction right now I have a habit of
like checking her thing so I'm just
gonna cut that habit off by blocking you
that's smart but it is like
it all doesn't [ __ ] matter I'm just
working on like so see bacon was on and
she did like our tarot cards and both of
us got one that was like about not like
reacting not having to defend yourself
not like just like
letting it go letting go of like my
revenge fantasies basically
you know like life will take care of
that for you yeah like everyone has
their you know comeuppance at some point
the Taylor Swift song Karma pretty good
off the new album really really applies
here have you seen Nicky speaking of no
she's in town oh oh she's not in your
movie that was me I was fishing
I was like what's she in town for
you're like Nikki which uh have you seen
us here Carlos thank you so much for
letting me eat you out today that was so
cute
bad friend's chorus you know here's the
thing one of these days I'm just gonna
say yes and then I don't know how you
would react
I'll I'll react in a good way
imagine seeing that head between your
legs oh my God
it's Benjamin Franklin email wait don't
you guys
should eat that for real I'll FaceTime
you yeah wait you have I do not can I
just say I don't want to be on that
first time
wait hang on you know we're gonna have
to do it with Annie we're gonna have
like you know um
um that one movie where they they open
up your eyes open right Clockwork Orange
when you did that we're gonna force your
eyes open like this we're gonna take
something hot like that too I was like I
want to [ __ ] her eye holes I was like I
want to stick my dick in her eye sockets
I'm Gonna Make You See Carlos bald head
inside in between you like I'm birthing
a baby
like that is what we're gonna do to you
that will be my reaction
and you know what on that note to our
slugs thank you so much for joining us
every single week we love you we live
for you we die for you please don't
forget to join us for the live stream
there's some plans there may be a stream
or two there's drugs
there's experimentation with young women
with young women why are you doing that
us we're young we're just young women
experimenting all right we'll see you
guys next week don't forget to like And
subscribe
foreign
[Music]